merci michael delafosse d'être avec nous
effectivement je le dis pour les
téléspectateurs qui ont entendu on
s'était vus à montpellier lors du débat
des municipales qui était avec le midi
libre et on a donc le plaisir de vous
accueillir pour la première fois dans
cette émission en tant que maire de
montpellier maire socialiste de
montpellier merci beaucoup
notre invité ce matin et pour cet hymne
tableau pendant 20 minutes en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et comme tous les jeudis c'est
l'excellent julien lécuyer bonjour
julien luc merci
genre est avec nous on va évidemment
parler du congrès des maires une kld
l'afp david lisnard le maire la
république en de cannes a donc été élu
hier président de l'association des
maires de france vous ne soutenez
comment vous avez réagi à ces du temps
on imagine que c'était de la
satisfaction mais est ce qu'il y avait
aussi un peu une part de soulagement
dans cette campagne qui a été immédiate
oui
[Musique]
moi je suis un maire nouvellement élu je
me suis impliqué au sein de
l'association des maires de france parce
que c'est un très beau mandat mr là
mêmes jouent un rôle important dans la
vie démocratique
c'est une association qui fédère les
35000 mère je me suis impliqué sur un
sujet qui m'est très chère quelles sont
les questions de laïcité qu'il nous faut
réaffirmer dans le débat démocratique
est une tradition existe à leymen c'est
de veiller à ce que toutes les
sensibilités travaillent ensemble à
gauche la droite pour faire porter des
sujets en commun puis identifier les
points sur lesquels nous aurions des
appréciations différentes et la
tradition était une liste de
rassemblement on trouve des gens de
gauche moi j'étais sur la liste de
monsieur lisnard au nom de des hommes et
femmes de gauche qui a des gens de
droite nous avons été il a été vu et
donc je m'en réjouis et je veux le dire
j'ai peu goûté
on tout le monde peut déposer des listes
mais j'ai peu goûté au de 24 dernières
heures de campagne je le dis j'ai trouvé
que la sortie de monsieur muselier
présent deux régions qu'ils président
qui fait son travail mais quand il a
expliqué que ce maire dans son palais
cette violence-là nice et dans son
palais des festivals en sérieux
participa à la qualité du débat
démocratique
ce que vous nous expliquer monsieur de
l'afo ce que
ce que les français peuvent voir comme
une cohabitation un peu un peu étrange
entre david lisnard car présentant quand
même d'une droite assez ferme si ce
n'est du rpt libéral conservateur et
vous qui est a priori aux antipodes des
convictions politiques de monsieur
lisnard vous pouvez cohabiter au sein
d'un exécutif de l'association des
maires de france sans difficulté et on
me fait un habitent le même pays la
france on partage la république les
députés oui ils ont justement il y a des
espaces où il y à des oppositions où il
ya des sensibilités qui s'expriment et
on n'est pas en permanence obligé pour
prendre un propos que parfois nous
utilisons se mettre sur la figure on
peut aussi trouver des points date de
travail ensemble et tout n'a pas
vocation à être des espaces daf mon
partisans et encore c'est pas votre
point d'accord avec monsieur disnat
d'accord avec monsieur lisnard c'est que
les maires ils jouent un rôle dans la
vie démocratique que les collectivités
territoriales sont des espaces de
responsabilités au plus près nos
concitoyens des espaces d'efficacité
comme on l'a vu lors de la crise
sanitaire mais si demain monsieur
lisnard propose une motion au nom de la
mf pour supprimer 500 mille
fonctionnaires comme le proposait séduit
droite il trouvera des maires de gauche
dont moi pour défendre une force du
service public et ce point de désaccord
ne sera pas porté par la mmf et nous
allons essayer de trouver des espaces de
consensus de propositions pourquoi pour
être plus efficace auprès de nos
administrés ce pays a besoin de se
penser d'une démocratie
partager d'exercice de la responsabilité
et de quête de l'efficacité de l'action
publique et donc moi écouter
les gens faut quand même il ya plein de
gens intelligents
quand même fait campagne de la fin sur
l'indépendance de l'association des
maires de france s était le ct le mode
david ménard en clair ça veut dire que
la liste la liste adverse c'était une
liste plutôt composée de maquereaux nist
est ce que quand même ça va être ça
l'association des maires de france une
sorte d'opposition nous mettre pouvoir à
emmanuel macron est nommé
enfin moi je veux dit très clairement il
ya le président de la république chef de
l'exécutif et l'association des maires
de france elle doit faire entendre sa
voix sur les différents textes
parlementaires sur le projet de loi de
finances dans l'élection présidentielle
à venir
quelle nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation pensait que le monsieur
merde le maire de sceaux philippe
laurent n'était pas en capacité de le
faire le maire de sceaux il n'a pas fait
le choix de composer une liste
respectueuse de l'ensemble des
sensibilités de notre vie politique
la liste sur laquelle j'étais moi je
suis maire de montpellier présente sa
métropole comporte des communistes des
écologistes des socialistes des maires
de droite pour avoir l'esprit qui a
toujours présidé à la ms de rassemblant
comme d'ailleurs je voudrais le dire la
france urbaine
l'association des grandes métropoles
modernes j'anime le groupe de travail
mobilité avec monsieur roux didier qui
est le maire de metz je suis le maire de
montpellier il est de droite je suis de
gauche mais on travaille sur ces sujets
il faut aussi que dans notre démocratie
il y ait des espaces on dégage dès
qu'est ce que c'est que cette arrivée de
monsieur disney ça ça se traduit un
changement à l'avenir du dialogue avec
avec l'état ou est ce que vous pensez
qu'on se rassure la continuité totale de
l'ancien président françois baroin à
chacun son style moi je veux d'abord
rendent un hommage très appuyé à
françois baroin je les ai découverts
dans mes fonctions je veux le dire je
crois que ça a été un très bon président
de la mf c'est une très grande figure
politique de la vie française je vous le
dis je vais vous dire pourquoi
d'ailleurs parce qu'il est d'une clarté
résolues face à l'extrême droite voilà
et il porte en lui l'héritage chiraquien
si je n'ai jamais soutenu jacques chirac
s'offre au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle ou en tant que français
quand il a refusé mais il a un cas il
incarne l'une de ses figures la droite
républicaine et je veux lui rendre
hommage david lisnard il a été le maire
qui s'est beaucoup d affirmer dans la
baie du confinement et tous les maires
d'ailleurs on était un peu à son image
les masques l'organisation de la
vaccination la protection de la
population
les travers administratif ou parfois
l'urgence pour protéger nos concitoyens
sont devenus des pesanteurs et qu'il a
fallu surmonter donc moi je aujourd'hui
on a un nouveau président ce président
n'est pas un monarque il est le
président d'un conseil d'administration
et associations d'élus et il doit porter
et je ne doute pas qu'il le fera 2
manière constructive
des propositions et bien pour que les
communes fonctionnent du mieux possible
dans l'intérêt de nos concitoyens dans
un dialogue respectueux entre l'état et
les collectivités et lors de la
présidentielle il faudra amener le débat
de la décentralisation car c'est une
question à la fois d'efficacité de
l'action publique et de démocratie dans
notés centralisation qui est normalement
on se doit de faire l'objet d'une loi la
loi 3ds qui a qui arrivent au parlement
mais qui revient au parlement mais qui
semble ne peut s'arrêter au milieu du
gué pour beaucoup de gens et ce qu'il
faudra la reprendre
est ce que vous attendez du président
mâcon qui doit s'exprimer cet après midi
devant les maires qu'ils axent un nouvel
un nouveau volet de cette cette
politique genou le 10
aujourd'hui notre pays est confronté à
des urgences la question de la
transition écologique tiendrons nous ou
pas en france l'accord de paris donc il
faut des infrastructures de transport
décarbonée nous voyons bien donc il faut
la sobriété énergétique de nos logements
c'est un enjeu de souveraineté
aujourd'hui on est comme dépendant des
russes et des des pays du golfe en
matière de pétrole et aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'à des choses qui ne
marchent pas ou qui prennent
anormalement trop de temps la france des
procédures tu la france des projets et
donc moi je plaide et la mf plaide pour
un nouvel acte de décentralisation pour
que l'on dise de manière lisible qui
fait quoi et à quel échelon on peut
faire mieux et vite aujourd'hui a
forcément transfert des compétences mais
clarification des compétences la
réplication et je le dis moi je défends
des transferts de compétences on voit
bien que sur les questions de santé on a
sans doute des choses à faire on voit
bien que sur la question de la
rénovation thermique de logements là où
les allemands réussissent nous on a des
chiffres extrêmement préoccupant
pourquoi parce que on a un problème de
lisibilité
donc voilà ça c'est des débats que nous
devons mener en tout cas l'erreur serait
de croire que recentraliser serait gage
d'efficacité
au contraire il faut décentraliser pour
situer au bon endroit la responsabilité
pour rendre des comptes pour mobiliser
les citoyens et donc c'est ça à la fois
moins que la mf nous attendons du
président de la république mais que nous
devons porter dans le débat de la
présidentielle parce que ce qui se joue
c'est la vitalité démocratique et
l'efficacité de l'action avant d'écouter
emmanuel macron cet après midi devant
les maires il en a reçu hier à l'elysée
qu'est ce que vous a dit moi je n'ai pas
pu y aller monsieur j'avais beaucoup
d'autres
non mais je la contrainte café que mais
il a reçu c'est la grande tragédie
il a fait la tradition républicaine le
président il a reçu les maires et c'est
très bien voilà et donc c'est tout à
l'heure qui donne va s'exprimer les
maires attendent
d'être reçus comment selon vous on sait
qu'il avait été huée en 2017 quand il
avait parlé de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation j'étais l'accueil watier
d'avoir je ne sais pas je je suis maire
depuis un an on ne tue pas le président
de la république même si on est en
désaccord avec le président de la
république et donc moi je suis maire et
le président de la république on
l'accueille de manière républicaine et
j'avoue j'avais été choquée même si on
peut avoir des désaccords c'est aussi
l'image que nous donnons de notre
démocratie en ce moment nous sommes sur
public sénat peut-être un jeune homme ou
une jeune femme qui s'intéressent à la
vie politique nous regarde quelle image
donnons nous on peut pas s'insurge et
des violences qui montent dans la
société et que parfois ceux qui ont des
responsabilités dans la société donne
des ailes voilà donc le chef de l'état
représentent les français on peut avoir
des désaccords j'en ai sur un certain
nombre de sujets je crois profondément à
l'autonomie des collectivités locales
mais on ne tue pas donc en tout cas pour
ce qui me concerne il sera accueilli de
manière républicaine et si demain c'est
un autre ce sera pareil je crois
peut-être à paraître surprenant sur ce
plateau mais je crois que
c'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord
sur un point qu'on doit en permanence
théâtralisée la conflit tu alité et
parce qu'à la fin elle nous impuissante
collective a remis les violences qui
montent dans la société d aller violence
envers les élus victime de menaces
d'agressions physiques elles ont triplé
l'année dernière hier le chef de l'état
à l'elysée a promis son soutien
indéfectible au maire il doit se
traduire comme ans pour vous écouter ça
c'est une bonne chose parce que
effectivement ceux qui exercent des
responsabilités qui donne du temps parce
que maire de montpellier moi je donne du
temps mais des collègues dans des
petites communes qui ont peut-être pas
autant de services d'administration que
nous avons à montpellier
c'est près de 70 heures par semaine
souvent des sacrifices de la vie de
famille et donc voilà quand des gens se
livrent à des agressions physiques
verbales ils s'en prennent à une figure
vous l'avez senti cette violence vous
mais bien sûr je vomissais mais bien sûr
j'ai été menacé aller à l'image de tout
ce qu'on voit dans la société donc on la
ressent moins sur un centre de prise de
position jeu et et
l'outrance l'a emporté sur voilà
monsieur le maire expliquez nous bon eh
bien il faut clairement comme on doit
soutenir les professeurs comme on doit
soutenir les policiers comme on doit
soutenir nos médecins et bien il faut
soutenir les élus de la république un
élu de la république il a pas vocation à
être jetés en pâture c'est dans les
dictatures les jette en prison
dans une démocratie un élu
si on en n'est pas d'accord on change au
moment des élections mais ceux qui se
livrent à des actes de violence doivent
être sanctionnés parce que dans une
démocratie la violence a eu des pépins
planchistes c'est de la proposition de
xavier bertrand la meije est dans un
état de droit l'individualisation des
peines est un principe fondamental voilà
parce que c'est comme ça que ça doit se
passer en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que aucune agression contre un élu de la
république contre un fonctionnaire de la
république contre tout citoyen la
réplique de douars et ce ne peut être
impunis voilà moi je crois à des règles
au respect et quand des gens malmène des
élus comme il n'aimerait pas être
malmené ils doivent être sanctionnés et
je le dis durement c'est une question
d'autorité république sur les questions
de sécurité questions qui préoccupent
évidemment les français vous vous êtes
beaucoup engagé sur ces questions dès
début de votre mandat dans votre ville
de montpellier vous avez mis en place
des partenariats avec le procureur vous
avez formé l'ap la police municipale ça
peut paraître peut-être atypique pour un
maire de gauche est ce que la gauche à
la trop longtemps abandonnés ces
questions de sécurité pour vous alors
j'aimerais bien que la prochaine fois je
revis en dise c'est normal que la gauche
s'occupe de la sécurité parce que la
protection la protection des des gens
qui habitent dans les quartiers des
classes moyennes la protection de chacun
elle est indispensable et c'est la règle
qui protège c'est la première des
libertés c'est la règle nommée une règle
et faites pour être respectées au sénat
et à l'assemblée nationale des lois sont
votées fixe un certain nombre de règles
qui sont le compromis qui garantissent
nos libertés et donc ceux qui
transgressent les règles ne font pas la
loi et donc ceux qui transgressent les
règles doivent connaître des sanctions
et quand des jeunes brûlent des
poubelles dans une quartier populaire
comme ça arrive souvent et ben moi je
suis un maire de gauche et je suis
désolé mais ce type d'incivilités doit
être sanctionné parce qu'à 2 heures du
matin on n'a pas être réveillé par une
odeur et avoir peur de voir sa voiture
brûlée pour laquelle on on a un petit
crédit ou un gros crédit d'ailleurs qui
coûte sur le sert et dont pour ça eh
bien il faut soutenir la police ce sont
des fonctionnaires moi j'ai une police
municipale et travailler à son
efficacité la coordonnée avec la police
nationale à montpellier nous achetons
des commissariats mobile pour être
présent sur les quartiers pour qu'un
dialogue police population qui est une
présence nous travaillons à créer une
police des transports 42 agents une
brigade du logement social parce que le
respect des règles c'est ce qui fonde
une vie en société sur le trafic de
drogue notamment puisque évidemment
c'est un bébé aucune
aucune impunité sur le trafic de drogue
l'espace public ne peut pas être content
il concerne des habitants de hlm qui
durent mesure va être expulsé ces
démarches que vous avez entamé mais moi
je suis très clair le trafic de drogue
il détruit la santé de tous ceux qui
consomment c'est d'ailleurs pas très
responsable de consommer de la cocaïne
parce que ça nourrit des trafiquants et
donc moi j'ai posé un principe simple
quand on a obtenu un logement social qui
est un acte de solidarité
nécessaire pour des milliers de familles
eh bien on se doit de respecter un
certain nombre de règles et si dans
votre logement social vous livrer à du
commerce de drogue eh bien vous
transgressé la loi et moi j'ai posé
comme principe que vous ne pourrez plus
rester dans le logement social et donc
je déposerai des recours en justice pour
demander l'expropriation de ce locataire
qui troublent l'ordre public et qui ne
respectent pas les lois communes de vie
en société je crois que vient passer
dans votre partie pardon vous reposer la
question donc à elle de la face mais ça
peut être un discours qu'on a l'habitude
d'entendre au parti socialiste
alors excusez moi mais pour beaucoup de
maires socialistes de gauche qui sont
réélus et bien élu d'ailleurs c'est
qu'ils s'occupent de ces sujets là
peut-être là où je j'apparais un peu
différent mais mes collègues mais moi je
parle beaucoup de ces sujets parce que
dès le début de mon mandat j'ai commencé
là dessus parce que je voyais bien les
problèmes qu'ils étaient confrontés je
les pose après la tâche est immense sur
les questions de sécurité y compris elle
doit être traitée avec rigueur avec
sérieux parce que les populistes le
instrumentalise la détresse des victimes
la responsabilité qui est la nôtre celle
des élus celle de l'état c'est de
s'efforcer de régler les problèmes et de
faire preuve d'une détermination sans
faille en tout cas moi vous ne trouverez
jamais pour dire c'est normal de bruit
une poubelle devant de la drogue donc ça
n'est pas acceptable parce que ça ça
pourrit la vie des gens et ce et c'est
pour ça qu'à la gauche doit parler de
ces sujets parce que ceux qui sont
victimes de l'insécurité
ce sont les plus fraîches ils ce sont
ceux qui gagnent 800 1200 euros par mois
ce qui est acquis on dit ah non c'est
pas grave on va pas en parler non la
sécurité c'est un enjeu essentiel comme
la santé comme l'éducation comme la
laïcité qui relève de notre pacte commun
qui est une valeur et justement on va
parler santé créé sanitaire jeux wii
autre actualité et la crise sanitaire
les taux d'incidence augmente partout en
france vous l'aurez évidemment doté
alors je sais pas ce qu'elle est la
situation à à montpellier c'est ce que
c'est préserver est-ce que c'est plus
grave
écoutez
j'ai visité les services de réanimation
du chu de montpellier
via des malades en réanimation et les
jeunes internes qui se forme en ce
moment depuis deux ans il voit arriver
en réa des patients qu'aux vide là
c'était que des non vaccinés 28 ans une
jeune femme de 28 ans il n'ait ils m'ont
raconté cette anecdote et merci de me
donner un tout petit peu de temps pour
la raconter ils étaient meurtris
quelqu'un qui n'étaient pas vaccinés qui
avait reçu une greffe du coeur était
décédé la veille de ma visite une greffe
du coeur une famille qui avait accepté
ce dont la personne avait refusé de se
faire vacciner elle en est décédé donc
moi je le dis la vaccination c'est ce
qui nous protège c'est ce qu'ils
protègent notre service public
hospitalier c'est ce qui protège la
population c'est pour ça que ma famille
politique est d'ailleurs les socialistes
les communistes ou prénom pour la
vaccination obligatoire quand il est
donc favorable et je suis très favorable
pour lie toutes les difficultés que ça
peut prouver est allé en termes
d'applications mais quelle difficulté
aujourd'hui les difficultés c'est quoi
c'est que des gens qui refusent de se
faire vacciner finissent en réanimation
et parfois meurent c'est aujourd'hui la
mobilisation de tous le confinement des
noms soient vaccinés je suis pour la
vaccination obligatoire je lui dis
aujourd'hui la vaccination c'est le
meilleur moyen pour sortir de cette
crise nous allons devoir prendre en tout
cas moi je prendrais j'en ai échangé
hier avec mon ami le maire de nancy
mathieu klein qui a été très durement
mis à l'épreuve le grand test sur cette
pandémie est par exemple à montpellier
notre repas des anciens qui est un
moment de convivialité vu l'arrivée de
la cinquième vague en responsabilité
c'est une décision très dure à prendre
je préfère pas le tenir parce que je ne
veux pas d'un seul coup que ce moment de
fête devienne un cluster nous devons
tenir dans la crise et tenir en
responsabilité pour protéger la
population mais la responsabilité c'est
que nous avons une solution c'est le
vaccin c'est pour ça je souhaite qu'il
soit obligatoire et personne ne devrait
être choqués de l'obligation vaccinale
aujourd'hui ça nous a permis d'éliminer
beaucoup de maladies infantiles et
d'accroître l'espérance de vie moi je
crois en la science et le vaccin
aujourd'hui c'est la meilleure arme
contre le coc vie 19 et on va terminer
en parlant d'elle dans la face que vous
soutenez bien évidemment alida go et la
campagne de la présidentielle talgo
entame à partir du 22 novembre le
traditionnel tour de france du candidat
à la présidentielle alors
disons le c'est une campagne qui pour
l'instant pour anne hidalgo que commence
metropia donc comme on dit
4 à 6% des intentions de vote est ce que
vous pourriez le tour de france va
suffire à relancer la campagne je peux
vous dire une chose aujourd'hui les
français les françaises en tout cas tous
ceux que je rencontre à moi ce sont les
montpellierains les montpellierains qui
sont pas dans la campagne présidentielle
il ya la crise sanitaire ça suffit à
expliquer le faible score de johan
olsson personnes voilà on y est on sent
que les gens smad on est dans un moment
où la campagne se prépare il faut donc
écouter pour travailler le programme le
plus juste les questions éducatives les
questions liées au travail les questions
liées à la santé les questions liées à
la sécurité vont être des questions
essentielles et donc c'est là dessus
donc il se travaille quelques ânes
hidalgo qui à mes yeux incarne une
gauche qui résolument pose les questions
éducatives les questions du travail qui
est au rendez vous des questions
écologiques qui sont indispensables pour
la jeune génération
parce que c'est elle qui va subir le
désastre si nous changeons pas comme
nous nous essayons d'agir à montpellier
avec la gratuité des transports eh bien
le week-end et puis pour tous les moins
de 18 ans et les plus de 60 ans c'est
pas tout le temps aller fin 2023 pour
l'ensemble des habitants hockey et
chaque fois que vous aurez une mobilité
décarbonée c'est gratuit parce que moi
je veux aider notre pays à tenir les
objectifs de la rythme sud de la fosse
avait un petit peu plus loin que ses
intentions de vote je ne sais pas si
vous avez eu le temps de voir le
baromètre ipsos le point qui vient de
sortir et c'est pas vraiment une bonne
nouvelle pour pour la maire de paris
son taux de rejet il est de 67% c'est à
dire c'est au même niveau que celui
d'eric zemmour et je vais même aller
plus loin c'est que parmi les
sympathisants du ps elle n'obtient que
45% d'opinions favorables pour 44%
défavorable il ya il ya plus qu'un
problème il ya une vraie menace un vrai
péril non écoutez le vrai menace ou le
vrai père il sait que la gauche ne fasse
pas entendre ses idées ses valeurs lors
de cette élection présidentielle et donc
à mes yeux celle qui incarne la gauche
c'est anne hidalgo elle est maire de
paris elle a le soutien de tous les
leaders de gauche européens pedro
sanchez olaf chaleur c'est très bien
mais il a surtout avoir le soutien des
socialistes français mais mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce travail de
rassemblement quand bernard cazeneuve
qui hier a eu des propos extrêmement
fort encore sur les attentats vient lui
apporter son soutien elle allonge le
soutien d'un ancien président de la
république françois hollande est
aujourd'hui les hommes et femmes de
gauche qui sont un peu déboussolés dans
cette élection et puis parce que depuis
2010 est non mais disons le
voilà aujourd'hui mais faut dialoguer
travailler sur des propositions avancées
sur un projet et une crédibilité
mais quand vous êtes maire en tout cas
moi je le mesure vous êtes mais quand
vous êtes mère laquelle tâche de ramener
les jeux olympiques que vous êtes primé
par l'onu pour votre action en faveur du
climat c'est une forme et une
crédibilité et je voudrais juste dire à
gonçalo de la famille qu'elle de la
plaque
c'est un très bon
parce que c'est la question du sérieux
la crédibilité dans une démocratie face
à vous avez évoqué ce que le débat est
quand même un peu nauséabond on donne
beaucoup d'espacé merci de m'avoir
invité à des gens qui sont quand même
capable de remettre en cause les valeurs
essentielles de la république et qui ont
bénéficié d'un une donc voilà il est
temps de se réveiller comme nous invite
anne hidalgo à le faire le débat doit
avoir lieu sur les idées pour répondre
aux problèmes des gens merci mont comi
cameron espère vous reviendrez nous voir
sur ce plateau merci
donner la parole à l'ensemble des élus
de la république oui
[Musique]